the layah heilpern show sponsored by step finance
your go to DeFI portfolio manager on solana
luno if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to another episode of
the lehigh plan show today is going to be so much
fun because i'm bringing a guest on who i think we
agree um on a lot of different issues in the world
right now and um i'm pretty sure he can articulate
many of these points better than i can so i'm
really excited to chat to him but before i bring
him on as usual this is powered by the vc firm
icon plus capital and is sponsored by blockfi i've
left a link in the description and in the comments
um if you want to check them out they offer
really cool interest rates i think around
11 um or something like that on your stablecoin so
it is pretty cool all right so let's get into this
joining me today is the host of the mark moss show
on iheartradio i think that kind of gives it away
it is um he's a freedom maximalist and the person
who's on a big mission to wake people up what's up
that's right you got that right thanks
uh thanks so much for having me it's a
pleasure to be here i'm uh happy to dig in yeah
i want to go for this um i'm not going i'm not
going to do any background stuff i want to go
straight into this but is that right in saying
you're here to wake people up and that's what i'm
trying that's what i'm trying to do you know i
think um the way that i see the world is that uh
i think we're kind of in world war three and it's
the governments versus the people and i think
really it's not a war people are afraid of you
know going to nuclear war right now i i don't
think that's you know i think that's not very
probable i think there's a low probability that
happens i think the real war is over information
and money war it's over information and money
and uh i made a comment that kind of turned
into a meme and i said we have memes and we have
bitcoin and they got nothing right so we have we
have the tools that we need to win but it's really
it's a war of information and i think we see this
um more now than ever before and so just like
the printing press changed things in the 1500s
the internet is changing things today and so
they've lost the narrative they lost their grip
alternative news like what you're doing like what
i do has taken off obviously joe rogan tucker
carlson are smashing whatever they control and so
they've lost their grip on information and they're
trying to get back that we can dig into that more
but i think it's a race and the race is can we
wake enough people up before they can reach their
end goal and that's right so i'm trying to wake as
many people up as i can yeah yeah no this is great
there's so much to get into um let's just go for
it okay so we're talking about let's start with
bitcoin um and we'll start with canada so i think
the narrative um surrounding bitcoin is slightly
changing um you know at the beginning of covid
i shouldn't even say that because of basketball
and stuff at the beginning of you know what yeah
yeah watch out um yes at the beginning of covered
um you know we were really pushing that safe haven
asset right especially because we saw the
markets crash bitcoin came fighting back
but now we're sort of seeing the whole
you know it's a hedge against tyranny
the idea that it's just humanitarian money
i think we saw even with ukraine around 4.4
million dollars in bitcoin being donated um
you know people being able to um use bitcoin
you know despite the canada freezing their bank
accounts so how is this going to help with mass
adoption bitcoin as this humanitarian um type
of money and i guess the whole um everything
that's going on in the world right now is kind
of helping sell it yeah well um humans are very
simple at their core right they were really
motivated by two things so humans want to
rush towards pleasure or they want to run from
pain and so we have those are the two main it's
the character of the stick those are two main
things that drive us as humans and so when uh
you know the crypto markets are going parabolic
it's sucking everybody in i want to get rich i
want to get rich everyone's making money but me
and it starts sucking people up and the and the
more that more people sucked in the more it goes
up and it turns into this parabolic run and that
but then when the blow off top happens and it
starts crashing then people run from the pain
and they want to sell right that's why it's very
volatile at the top but also back to the kind of
point that you're making is that we also again
motivated by pain so for example i believe in
going to the chiropractor i believe in having a
solid base and if my spine's in in proper position
the rest of my body works right um and i've gone
for most of my life and i really believe in it but
i don't typically go anymore until i'm in pain
the pain has to motivate me and so the reason
why i say that is back to bitcoin so if we look
at you know parts of the world in africa central
america where they have serious problems they've
moved on to bitcoin first because their pain
is high enough so um what we've seen in
obviously our you know venezuela 2500 inflation
or lebanon 98 inflation they switched out their
currency for them the pain is so high they're
moving to bitcoin as fast as they possibly can in
the united states in canada western europe they
don't really have that pain they've been mostly
motivated by pleasure i heard i can get rich
if i buy bitcoin or now chase a cryptocurrency
i called bitcoin the great bait and switch so it
sucks you in to make money and then you stay for
the freedom aspect but what we're seeing now is
the entire world has woken up to the actual pain
so the pain like i said in argentina venezuela
lebanon they see that but in the u.s and canada
we're like uh what do we need that for like our
money's like pretty good yeah i mean sure you know
it's the the fed created 35 more money we had 35
inflation but you know that's not as bad as 2500
inflation right so the pain wasn't high enough
for most people but all of a sudden in the last
whatever two to three weeks in canada we just saw
that your money isn't safe your money isn't your
money so the truckers the people that donated the
truckers got their money frozen and then what the
world just saw there's three global superpowers
in the world u.s china and russia three global
superpowers with nukes russia being one of them
and their bank accounts just got seized and it
was one thing if it was the truckers in canada
but now a sovereign nation with nukes and so
the world just realized really fast that your
money is not safe so the weird part of all of
this is we're kind of seeing it on both sides
right so we're seeing money being donated
to the canadians to fight the government
we're seeing money being donated to ukrainians
to fight the government but then there's also
the question you know is russia going to start
adopting bitcoin or any other cryptocurrencies
um to circumvent sanctions i know elizabeth warren
was saying something i didn't even read it i don't
listen to her stuff but i know she was saying and
if you say you know actually i did read it um she
said something like uh this is why we need more
regulation on digital assets or something like
that yeah so how do we explain to people that this
as much as it's for you it's also for your enemies
but it's still important like how do we because
my concern is we're gonna you know if russia do
start to circumvent sanctions using crypto
they could use any i don't really know um
maybe they'll use bitcoin but i worry that
we could end up being kind of like a client
in the environmental climate change issue that we
saw with bitcoin and elon musk you know last year
well a couple things i'd say first off i think
trying to discuss it at that level is at the wrong
level and so it's really much deeper problem so
like um really it's the money system that got us
to this point that we're at today so now oh should
should we ban bitcoin because russia wants to use
it i mean that's the conversation like um at a
two micro level we kind of have to zoom out that's
one thing i'd say the other thing that i would
say about that is that um to your point someone
might say they're our enemy and they're using it
so we need to ban that but everyone's an enemy of
somebody the world's never been more divided and
so whether you're left or right or red or blue or
whatever right somebody's on the other side of
that and so you're always gonna be someone's
enemy so you have to think about that i'm always
gonna opt for the side of freedom as you said
freedom maximalist and so a couple things i would
say um one is that um sanctions right that's the
tool the us dollar has been weaponized it wasn't
just elizabeth warren as a matter of fact brad
sherman from california has been on the news for
a couple of years now saying that cryptocurrencies
undermines the u.s dollar and it undermines
the us's ability to put sanctions on nations
like iran he actually said that and so if
on iran listening to that i'm like oh so it
takes away their ability to sanction us maybe
we should use that um and so freedom is messy
for you to have the freedom to say what you want
to say you might say things i don't like sometimes
but that's just the way it works and so the
freedom to transact i understand what you're
saying uh i think um yeah i don't know i don't
know if i answered that no it's fine i i think
we are going to get into like a little bit of a
war over it like i really do i think it's going
to be the same kind of freedom of speech wall
because you and i both understand that freedom
is messy and in order for freedom to um prevail
you are allowed to offend me and i can cry over
it but like i i still i still defend your right to
say it um but i'm concerned that we're gonna get
into this kind of tug of war with bitcoin well
we absolutely are because what's happening is
um sanctions right so we're we're either limiting
what people can do in the financial system or
in the case with russia potentially moving
them out of the financial system altogether
so if we kick russia out of the swift system out
of the banking system or limit their ability to
even use it for that matter then what do they
do they do they just go into a hole and just die
no they just figure out how to work around
it so if they really cared about keeping the
russia in then they would want to have them
inclusive if they kick them out all they're doing
is forcing them to use something different same
as the canadians so the canadians they were kicked
out their bank accounts were frozen et cetera i
know some of them started coming back online but
now all those people have to find a way to
survive without the financial system if you and
i were having a party or let's say i was having
a party and i said hey you're being too noisy
you got to go outside and hey you're doing this
you go outside and you go outside you go outside
next thing you know i'm the only one left at the
party and everybody else went and started their
own party and i have no control over that party
because i kicked them out of my party and so
that's kind of what's happening with the financial
system in canada kicking them out of the finance
system russia kicking them out of the financial
system they have no other choice but to find
another way now bitcoin sure cryptocurrencies okay
uh they just made a 650 billion dollar deal with
china to sell them natural gas in euros so should
we outlaw euros as well maybe right and so like
where does this go right if you don't use the
money that we say that we have complete control
and we kick you out of then you can't use
anything else like how does that even make
any sense okay we're going to get to the whole
complete control thing remind me i need i need
to we can talk about that yeah complete control
um and then the endgame and all that stuff but
something i've actually been really curious about
and i'd like to get your opinion on is you know if
we all do adopt this new system right to fight
tyranny and you know i'm i'm ready to do it um
we're all adopting it what seriously though
like what happens if the internet shuts off
yeah so that's a that's a that's a
big question that's asked all the time
um i think it's a little ridiculous and so what
i would say to that is i don't think in things
in terms of absolutes there is no absolutes in
life i think of things in terms of probabilities
aliens could come destroy the world tomorrow the
probability of that happening is barely above zero
right maybe there's it's not zero any anything
can happen right um so will what happens if the
internet turns off so like the entire world's
internet goes off forever and never comes back
the probability of that happening is almost zero
so the internet is a layer and so you have about
seven layers it starts with the wires the fibers
in the ground then it goes up to the switches and
then it goes into like the tcp protocols the ip
addresses the the dns domain name servers and
then the isps internet service providers um so in
china they have the great firewall of china right
so there's no google facebook none of that's
allowed in china but people use vpns and they
get around that um they can shut off the okay so
they that's the isp they write around that we can
use tor well let's say that they stopped that and
now the dns doesn't work anymore well if we still
have the ip address we can just go directly to
the website the internet is pretty censorship
resistant we know this because using bittorrent i
can still download music and movies they've never
been able to stop that so the the probability
of the entire world's internet going down
and never coming back is barely above zero um
they would be cutting off their own communication
now let's say that it happens more regional
okay so for example um before the pandemic
broke out hong kong was being taken over by
china and there was massive protests going on um
of course the world didn't come out
to protect democracy in hong kong like
they are in ukraine but that's a whole other
story but um when that was happening um china
was shutting down all the communications
in hong kong so they couldn't organize
so phones and internet were taken down to your
point in that in that area but what they did was
um on their phones they use something called mesh
networks and a mesh network allows me to build my
own network and so everybody that has this mesh
network on their phone we create our own network
and they can't stop that they can't shut that
down and so in hong kong they're using these
mesh networks and they're still using that to
connect to to uh share information and we can
even send bitcoin over a mesh network that's
really interesting um because i do that is one
of the things that does just concern me because
i know when we talk about low probabilities we'd
also had said you know there's a low probability
that the world would shut down for two years
we'd sort of think you know why would they do
that that would you know screw themselves um
that's kind of my my concern you know what i mean
yeah but like i said they they'd literally have to
rip the wires out right ground and okay great so
you ripped wires out of the ground now we have now
we have satellites yeah no i know i'm with you
um you know we saw what elon musk did recently
for ukraine which was really interesting um but
it's interesting because we've just gone from
well the world has gone from blm to covid
and it's gone from covid like straight to a
war now i want to just preface my next question
by saying all war is bad because apparently you
need to make that clear people don't think that
people are human enough to you know hate war um
or as bad all killings all over the world are bad
murders are bad i don't support any kind of war
um you know but my my question is it just seems
like the timing just seems off and then it's not
just the timing it's also the um i need to think
about the way that i say this um it's also the
the priority that it's getting right and
you know we saw just to say we saw you know
chamath a few months ago sort of talk
about how what's happening in china
um is sort of you know below his line of caring so
why is this not below everybody's line of caring
well we think whatever they want us to think
whatever gets the news whatever gets 24 7 rotation
whatever fills up our feeds that's what we think
about whatever they want us to think about um back
to your point though all war is bad sure you know
ten commandments thou shalt not kill i believe
that and um what's crazy about war is that um you
know people in the u.s don't hate the people in
russia people in russia don't hate the people in
ukraine it's the governments that me who do right
and so um that people have to go to war and kill
each other it's ridiculous the people in ukraine
don't hate the people in uh in russia there was
a there was a famous story and uh i think it was
world war ii and it might have been between the uk
uh i forget the details but they were in these
trenches for days or weeks and and there was
like this no this zone that nobody could pass and
they were just basically stuck there and it was
like christmas eve and there was like a ceasefire
and the soldiers like came out and started playing
some music and put some trees out and next thing
you know all the soldiers from both sides who
had been there for weeks or months hold up trying
to kill each other were out celebrating together
right we're all people we don't hate people
in russia ukraine whatever it's the leaders
that's the problem that we need to talk
about um so i agree with you war is bad um
but um i think it's in my opinion so from a
zoomed out lens this isn't really like a random
or a black swan so you talked about how did it
go from uh one narrative to the next and so fast
well i think if you zoom out and you look at
things a little bit differently from a bigger
lens maybe they become a little bit more clear so
what do i mean by that well um i've been doing a
lot of work into these um like three revolutionary
cycles that are converging right now so um history
although it progresses like exponentially
it also repeats over and over and over so
we have these these cycles that continue and the
reason why is because as humans we have that so
um there's a political cycle a 250 year cycle
there's a technological cycle that operates on
a 50-year timeframe and a financial revolution
cycle on an 80 year so an 80 a 50 and a 250
but all three are converging right now
which i believe explains why the world has
gone completely mad and why it's moving as fast as
it are as it is right now so uh there's a famous
quote from vladimir lenin from russia and he says
that there's decades where nothing seems to happen
and then there's days where decades seem to happen
and that's exactly kind of where we're at right
now right we just went from this whole covered
war for two years and now all of a sudden forget
no one even knows about that anymore kind of a
thing um and so this days or decades are happening
uh but this kind of fits into you i'm sure
you've heard about the fourth tourney which
is an 80-year cycle so um you've never
heard about the book the fourth turning
no everybody in bitcoin's heard about the four
tournaments uh you've probably you've probably
heard this so it's an 80-year cycle it's broken
up by four 20-year cycles and it's something
called generational theory so you've probably
heard that hard times create strong men oh
yeah yeah yeah i have yeah yeah so hard times
great strong men strong men create good times good
times create weak men weak men create bad times or
hard times and then the hard times create strong
men again so it's like this cycle and it's kind
of this generational theory and part of it's like
my grandfather was a farmer in iowa and i mean to
to live on the farm and work on farm is ridiculous
hard work people have this romantic vision of
it it's not easy my father grew up on the farm
but then left the farm to start a business and
he was the hardest worker i've ever met not but
not as hard as my grandfather my dad made me go
work with him when i was a kid and i hated him
for it and i'm an extremely hard worker because
of that but i'm not near as a hard worker as i
as my dad and my kids i can't even get them to
clear the table right it's like four generations
um so that's kind of how it works but what's
interesting is on these 80-year cycles
about every 84 years there's a populist uprising
or a regime change so 84 years ago was the end of
world war ii that was hitler mussolini in the
u.s we had fdr's new deal 84 years before that
karl marx wrote the communist manifesto which
led to the european spring which is the largest
revolution in history three times 84 equals 252.
so every 250 years there's a revolution cycle
so 250 years ago was the american revolution the
french revolution 250 years before that was the
protestant reformation so about every 250 years
there's this revolution that happens and of course
this is the cycle that we're in right
now so while a lot of people are like
well mark this uh this is a black swan event
who would have ever predicted that a virus
would come and the whole world would lock down
to the point you made earlier well history would
have predicted that as a matter of fact it tells
us right now we're in a regime change cycle and
a revolution cycle and it's happening right now
and as we just kind of talked about in hong kong
or and actually before the pandemic broke out
there was ten countries with over one million
people each protesting wow that was before the
pandemic so this this is not about a pandemic
this is not about some black swan virus this is
about a revolution and what is the revolution the
revolution is peak centralization and the world is
pushing back on peak centralization to move into
decentralization so 250 years ago the american
french revolution the americans were pushing
back on the centralization of the monarchy and
we created a decentralized government the united
states is a republic 50 independent states it
wasn't 50 at the time uh 250 years before that
was the protestant reformation which at the time
the church in the state had a complete monopoly on
control the printing press as i mentioned earlier
decentralized the information and when people were
able to read that they said wait a minute you've
been lying to us all this time we don't need you
and it moved into a decentralized thing so right
now we're at peak centralization it's easy to see
world economic forum world health organization
world trade organization i you know imf u.n et
cetera we're at peak centralization but the
world is pushing back we don't want that and
that's why there's um eruptions all over the
world right now if that makes sense it does
um i have several questions okay so the idea of um
peak centralization so okay so my most basic oh my
gosh well okay if it's a basic question or not
but okay let's go for it so peak centralization
um to what extent is this revolution then of
decentralization going to win because i think
that um we're seeing a lot of the infrastructure
um already be put in place um you know imagine
noise who i absolutely love um talks about um the
uh the the vax passports and how that's needed for
um cbdc's so the infrastructure is there and the
whole social credit system and stuff like that
um and you know it's very clear it's very clear in
my opinion that those in power have a huge amount
of control over the narrative the way we can
just go from two years you can go for not just
two years but you can go from an actual protest
in canada where people are literally imprisoned
in their own country they can't leave they don't
have a medical cert met a certain kind of medical
uh procedure happened to them to a war that nobody
is that nobody's talking about what just happened
the fact that we can do that so quickly just shows
how much um power these people the elite have
over what's happening and they're being honest
about it so the first question is to what extent
are we going to win this this revolution in terms
of decentralization yeah that's a that's a great
question first i'm going to answer it and then i'm
going to go back and explain it so we can win all
right okay we we will win we do win history tells
us that now um we'll go back and set that up um so
um kind of through the point that you're making
you're absolutely right and that is uh about the
social credit score system the cbdc's et cetera um
and and about the narrative so uh what do i mean
by that back to the 1500s right the church had
a complete monopoly on information and they um
told people that you had to buy your salvation and
you had to do these things for the church and all
these things but when people got the information
they said wait a minute you're lying to us this
is not how it goes and the church anyone who would
read that or speak out on it was labeled a heretic
you probably heard that word heresy and they
were they were killed right but it didn't matter
it didn't matter how many how hard they tried to
squeeze um it didn't matter how many people they
killed the information was out the technology
changes they lost their grip today we're in the
same situation where they've realized this peak
centralization wf imf etc they've realized that
they have lost the narrative to your point um like
i said tucker carlson um joe rogan they're getting
you know a hundred times more views than any
other of their of their sources and just like the
printing press the internet has disrupted their
grip now i think what they've done is they've
realized like shoot we're losing this we need to
crack down now we need to get this final piece
put in place or we're going to lose all control
and we're going to kill people to do it now not
killing people like in the process reformation
but killing people as far as de-platforming them
assassinating their character you know cancel
culture et cetera um and so i think what we're
seeing is that's that was the race that i
was alluding to the race is can they install
a social credit score system in place which
would include a cbdc right to include a global id
um can they install that before enough people
wake up and push back and overthrow that and so
that's really the race um i made the statement
that we win and i'll kind of explain that
but they they are trying their best to control
the nerve like i said we think whatever they want
us to think if they want us to think that covet's
the big thing it is if they want us to think that
canada is and now it's ukraine is the thing
but really it's the race to get that and so
um i was thinking that this was all coming
to a head remember these three cycles are
converging i haven't talked about the other two
the technological and the financial um but it's
all coming to a head right around 2025 and i was
think it's really like you know 2024 to 2026 right
and so i was thinking that's the time now what's
interesting about that is that the central bank
digital currencies are not ready right so china
has rolled theirs out china's rollers out but
the u.s fed doesn't have theirs the ecb doesn't
have theirs yet but we know that the fed's working
on it pretty fast right we know that they've been
working out for about a year and a half we know
that they just opened it up to comments about like
a month ago so it's coming along pretty quick i'm
guessing there's another 12 to 24 months before
it's ready to roll out and this whole social
credit score system doesn't really work until they
get that cbd see it's kind of that last piece they
need in there and so i think if you understand
that or i should not understand it but maybe
kind of see what i'm see what i'm going with this
that's the goal if i was like herding cattle or
sheep across the countryside for example my goal
is to move these sheep across the countryside and
get them into a pen over here at the end but you
know i have a lot of land to cover and so i have
to kind of push him here and i have to kind of
push him here and i have to kind of push him here
and so over here is the push from the virus and
over here is the push from the protest and over
here is the push on the cyber pandemic right and
each one of these is pushing us to the ultimate
goal which is the social credit score system so
none of these pieces the the past the vaccine
passport none of those pieces are the ultimate
goal it's one push to get us to the ultimate goal
which is the social credit score system and it all
hinges on that cbdc without freedom to transact
there is no freedom period so i have the i have
the right in the united states i have the freedom
the first amendment guarantees me the right to
assemble to go protest or whatever well if i
don't have money to put gas in my car to drive to
the assembly or buy a bus ticket to go simply i
have no freedom i have freedom of speech well if
i have no money to buy a computer to post online
or print a pamphlet or build a website i have no
freedom of speech i have the freedom of religion
well if my church can't afford to pay a payment
on a building or can't pay their staff there's no
freedom of religion so there is no freedom without
the freedom of payments and that's what the cbd
that you know that's where they come in if that
makes sense and so i think what they've realized
over the last two years they're losing their
grip and they had to do something they needed
to really escalate this speed this up to try to
hang onto that grip the problem is the more they
squeeze the more people push back newton's third
law says in physics is each force has an equal
and opposite reaction so the more they squeeze
the more people push back but the more people
push back the more they squeeze the more they
squeeze more people push back and now we're at
this situation where it's escalated to the point
where they're literally kicking people out of the
financial system and forcing people to go build
a parallel society which is a whole other topic
but the the thing with russia does confuse
me because it's not as if you know russia
is this noble country like they're doing some bad
things right like i've seen their bombs going off
um in ukraine like that's obvious um but what
i don't understand is how that comes into play
with everything that's going on um i'm not
saying it's not real like let's just be clear
obviously not saying that's not real um but but
there's something going on like it's strange yeah
that we've just gone from one narrative to another
and also sorry just to say as well and also just
like the amount like i'm saying earlier the amount
of priority um ukraine is getting in the media
yeah it's very interesting um it's it's a weird
time where we don't know what to believe anymore
right we know that our governments have lied
to us non-stop they've they've admitted that
they've lied to us they've admitted that they've
run psyops psychological operations against us
um we see our media using techniques like um
nlp neuro-linguistic programming against us
um and so we that now it's like we don't know
who to trust us like that boy who cried wolf
and we just can't trust them anymore and so
it's very difficult to know what's going on
yeah again i think if you zoom out um and look at
really this peak centralization i think that the
world has been taken over by bankers so if you
had like a business org chart the way that the
world was formed at the very top sits the bis the
bank of international settlements they're at the
top of the org chart and then below that then you
have the um the world economic forum and you have
the imf and these are like the policy makers so
they set these policies and they push them down
below that you have the governments and those are
the policy enforcers then you have the media that
distribute those policies the information and then
we have us the people at the bottom and so um when
you look at that and what's the goal here well the
big goal if they want to get the whole world into
this type of a system with peak centralization
is they have to bring down unfortunately and i
hate to admit this because i'm an american but
they have to bring down america america is the
shining example on the hill of freedom it's the
the the greatest experiment that's ever been done
has brought more people out of out of poverty
than any experiment in the history of the world
and we're the only nation in the world that has
guns and so the united america america has to fall
and we want to transfer the power from the west
which is america western europe canada et cetera
and it has to transfer from the west to the east
and so if you if you would agree with that or
maybe at least kind of see what that picture may
look like then maybe it brings a little bit of
clarity to this war with russia because really
what's the objective here right the objective
is to bring the us down and push power to
the east so we can install a social credit
corps system so what's going on with the war and
again i'm not saying this is fake um there are
i believe there are real bombs being dropped in
ukraine and i do believe people are really dying
um but is it part of the narrative maybe maybe not
um i don't i don't uh and just to be clear i don't
view this as like some conspiracy where uh
five people in a room have kept power over the
world for the last 500 years i look at it more
like if you see a flock of birds flying around
and they all kind of keep this formation as
they're flying they didn't sit on the ground and
say hey larry over there you take the left corner
and bob you go over there on the right like they
didn't plan it out they just they happen to just
kind of move together and so that's kind of the
way that i see it this isn't like some like five
people in a room but it's like they're all working
together but if you if you look at it through
that lens where it's a coup the world's been
taken over by the central bankers they're all kind
of working together in this power like the policy
makers world economic forum imf et cetera and the
and the goal is then to install the social credit
score system so we have to bring the us down right
have to kind of destroy that example and then get
rid of guns et cetera and transfer the power to
the east so then now let's look at russia and
ukraine through that lens okay so then um there's
a war with russia and what's happening well one
would look like the world still is fighting for
democracy so we don't look like we've gone too far
two really what we're doing is destabilizing the
markets and destabilizing the u.s dollars reserve
currency status we're pushing russia out of
either either out of swift or sanction them very
difficult to force them to find another option
they've now just made deals with china to give
them their energy so what does china really really
need china really really they don't have resources
right they don't have water they don't have
energy they don't have like coal they don't
have natural gas they don't have wheat but they
do now they just got all that from russia and
why did they get it from russia well because
russia was selling all their energy to europe
because europe decided not to get theirs out of
the ground anymore and so they were dependent on
russia for it but now russia just
made a deal to give it all to china
so what happens to europe western europe and
america now no small kids they fall and what's
the goal but what's the goal to bring those down
so we can transfer the power so i think if you
look at it from that lens maybe it gets more
clear or maybe i'm just crazy no no no i get
it i get it um my question mike my question is
i often think that um you know those in charge
um of america let's just look at america for
a second pretty bad people right like it for
me i think i don't just think biden is senile i
think he's bad as well i'm same with kamila harris
um and so my confusion would be why would they
want this war if that brings the west down
so again back to that org chart um the governments
are actually like on the third row down there
they're like more policy enforcers and so
um an example of this and if you look back
so back to kind of this world economic forum
and and they meet in davos every year right
in davos switzerland and i think it was 2017
um donald trump then president donald trump
went to um davos and he gave a speech and he gave
a speech that said um because at the time the u.s
had just gone into the the paris agreement or the
paris accord i should say and the paris accord is
basically a way that we lay down our sovereignty
and and uh comply to all these rules that the
i um ipcc or the wf put out and donald trump went
there and he said the us is a sovereign nation
the us will never lay down our sovereignty to
the rest of the world we will my job is to look
out for the american people now we're always
going to be willing to work with everybody else
but my job is the america america first right
that's what donald trump ran on america first
make america great again he says that the us
will never lay down in sovereignty at that point
at that speech is when the entire world came after
him all guns blazing no no no no the u.s needs to
take its place now when donald trump left office
and obama i mean you know biden took office again
what was the very first thing that they
did on day one they rejoined rejoined
and laid down the america's sovereignty
to the ngos non-government organizations
um why though like why why why is it so political
like why do you have a republican doing one thing
i know he's kind of an independent
but and then why why do the democrats
do that i mean surely it's still america first
regardless of which side you're on well it's not
america first when obama was in office before
no i know but one obama well when obama was in
office before he was the first president
that started going around and apologizing
for america to the world obama started apologizing
he started um he brought the you in into the
united states why to lay down his sovereignty to
work on this globalist agenda right so you're so
you're basically saying that the democrats or very
key people i don't i don't want to i don't want to
say left or right democrats or republicans okay i
think that the establishment is all in on this and
so again peak peak centralization we're going into
what i'm calling a blow off top of centralization
and so we've been going we've been we're in this
parabolic run into centralization and we've all
laid down like the government just take care
of education oh the government just take care
of healthcare oh the government just take care of
everything right and so we've given the government
the nanny state everything and we're at this blow
off top all the world leaders have started to buy
into these bankers because how did they do this
it's always about the money right so it's a coup
of the bankers at the top so you mentioned earlier
how did the whole world lock down at the one time
that's that's easy that's easy i can explain
that in a second tell me yeah sure easy so they
went to each country and they said hey um you
know per our models the whole world's gonna die
and uh your entire nation's gonna be completely
ravaged and you're gonna go bankrupt because
there's gonna be no tourism there's gonna
be no food it's gonna be famine and you're
all gonna die but but don't worry don't worry
we got your back what we're gonna do is we're
gonna give you you know 500 billion or uh 700
billion or 900 million or whatever the amount is
um and and we're going to help you we're going to
give you all that money so you you don't die your
country's good is that cool okay but you know
in order to do that and to save the world we're
going to give you that money but you needed
to kind of follow the protocols that we set
and they all did now we know this to
be true because multiple countries
um told us this so like the president of belarus
the dictator whatever you want to call him um they
he kept turning down their offers turning down
their offers and finally it was like 900 million
i talked about this on peter mccormick's podcast
they fact checked me in real time and they found
the headline to show that but multiple nations
have have said that and uh that's what happened
they paid them to do this so how do all these
nations go along with it um they do it through
the money right it's the bankers that took over
the world this is so fascinating um because
so at first i was i was quite upset to be i know
it sounds kind of ridiculous but i was quite upset
to be watching or living in a time where we have
these lockdowns like it was very difficult um but
now i'm kind of grateful to be watching all of
this play out like for me it's insane um and then
el salvador just comes right into this to me el
salvador is like at the center of all of this um
because because like you said it's all about the
money right and not all countries are following
what's going on so like dubai had a little bit
of a lockdown but then it just stopped so like
dubai is very much out of this i think
you have israel for example who pushed
everything so hard the hardest yeah and i'm
not surprised because for me like israel was
just an explanation of america yeah well everyone
everything's ending because of course it's ending
but i mean last night at the state of the union
you know none of the none of the people on there
were wearing masks and they were all shaking
hands it was just it was just gone so since and of
course because the media has got us all hey look
over there we don't notice that oh wait a minute
you mean the cdc just came out and said everything
that everyone that was d platform for saying these
things they were right all along but you'd never
admit that because oh look over there by the way
i'm with you i'm absolutely with you which is why
i just like i refuse to give so much attention to
things which i wouldn't usually give attention
to um but just on the previous point about it
all being about the money um el salvador is
clearly not in this in this globalist you know
club right like that is very exciting and they
have a lot of a lot of they're coming under a
lot of fire because of that right so let's so
let's go into that because so firstly it's all
the about the money because they're not in that um
you know they can actually promote healthy eating
and healthy this to fight off the the big bad
virus right which was amazing to see um you know
naive buchely i think he even quoted um biden
this morning or last night um with the iranian
people which was amazing um so so how much trouble
are they gonna be in and and you know what other
countries aren't part of this big globalist agenda
that can also start raising money through bitcoin
bonds and things like that yeah well um it you
know again right we've been we've we've been lied
to we know we've been lied to they've admitted
they've lied to us they've admitted propaganda
and psyops against us they admitted that they um
caused more fear to get people to comply they've
admitted this this is stuff that's been in writing
and been on interviews and so yeah now we're very
skeptical and now it's hard to believe anything
and so um i try to i try to always remember that
because i don't want to get too skeptical once you
start believing in conspiracies everything is a
conspiracy and that's not true either um however
that being said multiple leaders of countries in
africa in uh in haiti they told us that they were
getting bribed to do this and then multiple ones
that didn't go along with it ended up dead and you
know i'm sure it was all just coincidence but um
it's kind of weird right now as far back to
back to el salvador um he's coming under a
lot of fire a lot of fire right heavy fire from
the imf for not going along with it and i just
saw i believe yesterday before there's a new bill
that the united states is trying to put forward um
that that wants to go after el salvador
because of bitcoin as well because he's
destabilizing the financial system supposedly
what little el salvador tiny tiny el salvador is
stabilizing the yeah well because uh because
of uh you know terrorism because the people
could terrorists could be running money through
there supposedly um you know never mind the 80
billion dollars in weapons or you know 800 million
dollars of weapons that we gave to afghanistan you
know afghanistan has more blackhawk helicopters
than the uk does now never mind that you know the
little bit of money you run through el salvador
could be the problem but um there's a bill that
the united states is putting together right now
to find ways to go after el salvador because of
bitcoin um obviously the imf is super mad about it
and the bis they've been making lots of comments
about them destabilizing the financial system so
i think it's going to be a big uphill road for el
salvador obviously i'm rooting for them i've been
down there working with bitcoin beach i love it
what i'd really like to see is we really need
more nations to jump on board with this so
let's hope we're hoping that this bond sell kicks
off gets oversubscribed and more nations want to
jump into that i think fidelity put out a report
they said they think that um i think with two or
three more sovereigns will come into bitcoin this
year um and we really need to see that because if
el salvador is just out there on their own
i mean it's going to be dangerous for him
which do you think will come next i know
panama have introduced um a similar bill
but i'm not sure yeah um you know brazil
brazil's been talking about it costa
rica's been talking about it we've seen like
uruguay talk talking about it um i would say
you know panama has uh panama is likely you know
uh the the u.s is going to be the last nation
because they have the adult they have the dollar
right the reserve of course um nations that don't
have their own um that don't have the dollar
would be more likely um specifically ones that
maybe use the dollar right so if on my own nation
with my own currency i might not want to give up
control to print my own currency but if i'm using
the dollar i have no control over that anyway so
why not just switch over so i would say it's going
to be nations down there that use dollars already
well the next one i guess is tonga but that's
kind of so tiny it doesn't really matter uh not
it doesn't matter sorry if you're uh tongan uh but
uh but yeah maybe panama uh maybe costa rica maybe
brazil probably one of those nations any thoughts
on turkey yeah i mean turkey could really use it
for sure lebanon could really use it um i don't
know i don't i don't i don't have a prediction on
that but but back to the kind of where we started
earlier which is uh when the pain is high enough
remember pleasure and pain and right now people
are being motivated by pain most likely and so
turkey obviously has massive pain there um lebanon
has massive pain there um i saw a report that said
um in russia i think a couple days ago bitcoin
transactions were up 250 percent in a day because
the pain was so high and so yeah turkey um any
anything that was ukraine i think it was ukraine
the 200 one i think that was ukraine oh was it
ukraine was it yeah i think it was bit yeah yeah
i thought um either way one of those um yeah there
was an article that came out said putin said that
if they get hit with sanctions hard enough
they would come after citizens deposits
so if i was a citizen in russia and i saw that
headline i would probably want to get my money
out of the bank account right um wait just on that
point though because i saw mastercard and apple
i didn't even read it properly what did they do
because i saw um on the tube people or we call it
the cheaper in london um you know on the train on
the train people weren't able to use their apple
pay to get on public transport were you following
what happened no i didn't hear about that
yeah mastercard and apple have done something
i don't know i can guys you can ask me in the
comments because i'm not gonna quickly surf the
internet but um yeah mastercard and apple started
stopping yeah go on let's have a
look i can't remember what it was
in in the uk no no in russia oh in russia
before apple joins other global
giants in exit yeah visa masters
block russian financial institutions
yeah ukraine war long lines for atms in
russia as west restricts cashless payments
by the time you have to wait in the line it's
too late just for everybody listening don't wait
until you have to wait in line it's too late but
yeah i see visa mastercard blocked russian banks
from payment networks that's probably what you're
talking about yeah that's it that's it i mean why
are they doing that it's so weird why didn't
why didn't they do that in other countries i
know we've gone through this well we're calling
out um there was headlines in the united states
of uh of of kicking all russian students out of
the country that's awful and ridiculous and and
that and back to my point um as an american nobody
in america is mad at russians nobody in russia is
probably mad at people in ukraine it's the leaders
they're the ones causing all these problems
yeah i'm reading just through some of the
the comments that people are saying um
and that's why we always say with bitcoin it's
always fix the money fix the world it's all about
fixing the money and and there's a million reasons
why it all boils down to fixing the money but
these world leaders get all their power by having
a money printer by controlling the money printer
which is of course what we're seeing play out now
with russia and kicking them out and sanctions
and what if they go to a different currency and
blah blah blah blah nobody should have that power
so ted cruz did this speech um did you see the
speech about bitcoin i saw i saw um a clip i saw
some clips of it i didn't see the whole thing
but yeah it wasn't from the clips i saw it was
good yeah it was a pretty cool speech um but
he kind of put this real political um spin on
bitcoin and i'd love to hear your thoughts because
before we go into it my perception right is like
the technology is apolitical but i just can't be
convinced that the ideology is apolitical because
to me it's just not well um one i would say that
uh i don't know if i would necessarily agree with
your statement that he put a very political spin
on it oh he said he said liberals don't like it
he said liberals don't like it because they can't
control it i think that's yeah no he yeah i was
going to say he did he did say that but what
what the where i see a little nuance to that
is that in the united states and and probably
i'm sure over in western europe as well um
is now like a extreme right-wing view to like want
freedom to me that is not political i want freedom
now um donald trump i mean he's an authoritarian
too he wanted to also tell me what to do no he
didn't want to he didn't want to control me as
much as biden did per se but they both wanted to
tell me what to do they're both authoritarians i
want freedom i want nobody to tell me what to do
so which party am i for i've always said that um
i'm for the party that gives me more freedom and
less government which one is that right i don't
know i don't know which one that is but is that is
so so to that comment that he made um the liberals
or the left or whatever he said once you restrict
your movement restrict your money restrict
your payments one that's true um and two um
that the fact that i don't want my money or my
freedom restricted does that mean that i'm the
opposite party and so that's where i i think like
i said freedom has become like political but it's
not like freedom to transact or freedom to live
my life why is that political because that's the
libertarian that's the libertarian way right and
libertarian libertarianism is a political ideology
yeah i suppose i suppose and i know what you're
saying i mean a lot of people were mad about
ted cruz coming down and kind of claiming it and
part of the reason why is back to where we started
which is if russia starts to use it that's a way
to demonize it if if ted cruz and the republicans
use it it's a way to demonize it um the problem
is is that when we saw um when blm and antifa were
burning down the united states everywhere i met
a lot of blm rallies they were on stage telling
people to get your money out of the banks and
buy bitcoin so blm and antifa were using it and
that's certainly not republican um so they were
saying to do it um and now the republicans say
this so bitcoin is money for enemies bitcoin is
for everybody and everybody can benefit from it
um it's a tool right a screwdriver could
fix my car but a screwdriver could also stab
somebody as well right and so it's like how do
you use that tool unfortunately both sides are
going to use that tool to your point though and
again not to get political but one side does seem
more bent on really imposing their regulations
on you and so i guess it does work against that
do you think that in the next
election it's going to become a key um
like voting point well it already is so in the
united states we have midterms coming up here
um at the end of the year towards towards the
end of the year in the united states and we've
already seen many people trying to run on
this pro bitcoin platform so for example
yeah and i don't really like it either and i'm
afraid that people are going to fall for this
um so for example the mayor in new york kind of
ran on this i'm going to make i'm going to make it
the greatest bitcoin city and then all suddenly
works to shut bitcoin mining down like wait a
minute all these people that voted for that kind
of got the bait and switch um in uh in california
i mentioned earlier rep brad sherman who's
been one of the biggest outspoken critics of
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies because it takes
away the us abilities sanction um there's somebody
trying to run against him erica rhodes i had her
on my radio show and so she's running on this pro
bitcoin platform but then she's pro welfare and
pro ubi and um i don't see how those go together
because if i can't create money from thin air then
how can i have a ubi right so um i would i would
tell people to be aware of this we see in um in uh
in texas right now texas being this big free state
uh kind of the bitcoin capital of the united
states really the bitcoin capital of the world
probably with mining power anyway uh governor
abbott is facing uh re-election and there's people
challenging him and they're running on pro bitcoin
stuff like we're gonna make bitcoin legal tender
or we're gonna put laws in to protect bitcoin
so um i do see that now i guess to your question
will we see that in the next presidential election
it's two years away or no it's a couple years away
uh yeah two years away um my prediction says
probably no um two years is a long time right now
um i would say no i think a day is a long time
yeah i mean uh going back to kind of where i was
talking about these three converging cycles which
we didn't get all the way through but i was saying
it kind of comes to a head around 2025 which is
really like 2024 to 2026 kind of um i think things
continue to get worse for the next couple of years
um so i would guess that uh my prediction says no
i would say that the president doesn't run on that
in two years i'm just gonna pick you up on that so
you said we didn't get through it i want it i do
want to get through it um so you predict that it
gets worse up until 2025 where we hit a crescendo
is that correct yeah the blow off top that's what
i'm calling yeah the blow off top i like that
okay so we hit the blow off top and i know that
the the the agenda is 2030 that's obviously being
sped up to 2025. um what happens in 2025. well
i just think it's the blow off top right so if
you look at financial markets so if you look at
you know the dot-com boom or look at you know
bitcoin in 2017 et cetera and you see back to the
pleasure in pain it starts sucking so many people
in that it goes into this parabolic run now if you
study any blow-off tops in financial markets the
reason why it starts going so high is because it
starts sucking everybody in but you also know at
the very top is when it becomes the most volatile
it's super volatile top and then it blows off
boom right and crashes back down and i think
that's what we're seeing um from centralization
or socialism or whatever you want to call it today
whereas i kind of made the case earlier it's
like hey government you just take care of
education and day care and you take care of
health care and you take care of everything
we've just assigned everything to the nanny
state and we're kind of getting this blow off top
and now it's getting very volatile right now all
across the world people are pushing back there's
protests going on everywhere not because of a
virus because of centralization what they're doing
is they're pushing back on governments restricting
their freedom now the virus was a reason to
do that the money could be a reason or xyz
whatever could be the reason now potentially war
this is another uh i'm gonna jump into this rabbit
hole real quick um yeah so i made the case earlier
that this was really a war on information right
that's the war just like in the 1500s it was a war
on information today it's a warrant information
because they're losing their grip on the narrative
now if if we're in a war and we're fighting to
get information out there they're fighting to
censor information so it doesn't get out
there right that would be the battleground
so our job you and i we're creating content trying
to wake people up to this what are they doing to
win the war well they have to stop people like
us from getting information out there okay so
if you maybe see things through that lens well how
can they do that how can they stop us from putting
information out there well if you're in china
under a credit score system you say something
bad about the government they just disappear
you um they can't really do that in the u.s
they can't do that in the us they can't do that in
the uk in the us we still have freedom of speech
kind of obviously we can be platformed so twitter
youtube et cetera can kick me off but other than
kicking me off of the main platforms what can
they really do they don't have a lot of options
unless maybe they do hmm so what could be a
good reason to have extra powers to take away
people's ability to say things well if we look
back through history we can see at least four
times in the united states they've taken people's
ability away to say things so in the late 1700s
the sedition act of 1798's edition act of 1918 the
smith act i think 1940 and basically what happens
is in a time of war if anybody were to say
anything about the government or the leaders
that could make them look bad or somehow discredit
them it's punishable up to 20 years in prison
under a war under a war now
we're going to war right
are we really going to war is it a made for tv war
i mean people are really dying i'm not saying that
but could war be used as a way
to win the war on information
how else can they stop it because they can't
stop the internet right i've already kind of
given that case they can't stop the internet they
can't stop bittorrent from downloading movies
and they can kick people off of youtube but
they can't stop them putting up on decentralized
platforms like you know block blockchain like
odyssey or whatever right but what if they could
put them in prison for 20 years now in china
they can but the u.s they can't well actually
they can they've done it multiple times in history
under war hmm that's kind of interesting isn't it
so 20 25 you feel like 25 no i like this no it's
cool so 2025 you feel we that's the turning point
yeah and so a couple things about that so one
we talked about this political revolution cycle
there's this 250 year which we're kind of hit that
crescendo but then we have the the technological
revolution cycle so that operates on a 50-year
timeframe it's 40 to 60. just like uh seasons
on a calendar it says spring starts this day but
doesn't mean the weather changes that exact day
um so technology cycles are like uh 40 to 60 years
let's call it 50. now a technological revolution
isn't a new technology a new technology is like
an iphone that's cool uber that uber's cool right
a technological revolution is something that
changes the course of humanity there's been
five industrial revolution brought people from
farms and put them into cities and factories
um mass production et cetera um heavy machinery
um two we had steam engines and railways so all
of humanity people walked and rode horses
now we had steam engines we could move stuff
across continents then we had electricity and
steel all of humanity people had candlelight
and now we had electricity we also had
steel we could build skyscrapers and bridges
another 50 years after that we had the age of
oil and automobiles and mass production so for
all of humanity people walking around horses and
now we had cars pretty cool uh then we had 1971
was the age of the microprocessor which brought
us telecommunications it brought us the internet
brought us personal computers brought us mobile
phones um everything that we have today 1971 plus
50 years puts us at 2021 right about now and the
new technological revolution that we have today
is decentralized technology it's bitcoin
now bitcoin when when electricity came out
what happens as humans is is uh we can't really
imagine the future we try to take something new
and we try to understand it by
comparing it to something that we know
if you're trying to explain um something to a
blind person be very difficult because they don't
have any reference to anything right but we try to
understand it by something we know so for example
when electricity came out what is this thing well
it's kind of like a way to get light without a
candle it's kind of like a digital candle well
that's stupid what do we need that for candles
have been light for 5 000 years and look how cool
it is it's portable i can carry it around i don't
even need all these wires right well electricity
was it was a way to get light but of course it
became so much more right when the internet first
came out what is this thing well it's a way we can
send electronic messages and we have these like
message boards maybe one day we could even buy
stuff online but of course today we have you know
our cars hooked to something called a cloud using
something called social media to like navigate
us around traffic we didn't know that um and so
bitcoin what is this decentralized technology
well it's kind of a way to transfer money
store money well it is that yeah it is that but
it's going to be so much more it will change
the course of humanity and of course problems are
supposed to come to our solutions are supposed to
come to problems so the problem that we're having
is peak centralization the problem that we have
is unlimited money printing the problem that we
have is a set of people that constantly change
the rule on us not ruled by law but ruled by men
the problem that we have is censorship not just
in censorship where i can't say what i want on
youtube but as i said earlier without the freedom
to transact there is no freedom that's censorship
those are those are problems that we have so the
solutions would be something with a fixed supply
cap instead of sensual control something that
nobody can control instead of something that's
sensorable it's something that's censorship
resistant those solutions and so it's interesting
that on a 250-year timeframe we have a political
revolution happening and on a 50-year time frame
we have a new technological revolution that gives
us exactly what we need at the exact same time
which is pretty interesting the third one is on a
80-year time frame we have a financial revolution
cycle so about 80 every 80 years the financial
system gets reset 80 years ago approximately was
the bretton woods agreement the bretton woods
agreement was the entire global financial system
was reset onto a one-world currency a gold-backed
system the dollar of the reserve other currencies
pegged at the dollar and last year the imf
called for a bretton woods ii that's their words
a bretton woods ii well what was bretton was one
oh that was a reset of the entire global financial
system onto a one world currency and now they're
calling for that again what would the bretton
woods 2 be well um that's a good question so a
lot of people ask you know will the dollar remain
as the reserve currency uh will we go back to the
gold standard like peter schiff thinks would we go
to like would we go to a digital yuan will it be a
cbdc like an imf sdr backed a cbdc but i think
everybody's looking at from the wrong perspective
so they're all looking for a centralized answer
but the future is decentralized so bitcoin has
been my reserve asset we see fortune 500 companies
like microstrategy it's their reserve asset
we see nations like el salvador it's their
reserve asset so the i think the future is much
more decentralized and so everyone's looking for
that centralized answer but back to kind of this
coming to a head in 2025 and so the financial
system um the the bankers have two tools right
interest rates and monetary supply interest rates
are zero or negative in most parts of the world so
that tool's gone they have monetary supply but
how much more can they create they've created
over 300 trillion dollars in 50 years already
20 trillion just in the last two years they keep
printing but inflation's raging so that tool is
pretty much done if you and i were playing a game
and we're out of moves what do we do
well let's reset the game and play again
that's a bretton woods too now i've been thinking
as i kind of said earlier that they wanted to keep
it going so a lot of people are like can the
fed keep the markets from crashing can they
can they give us a soft landing could they
taper and raise rates without crashing the
markets can they they don't want the markets to
crash right or maybe they do that assumes that
assumes that you have a bias that they want
to keep the markets from crashing but what if
they do want them to crash how do you reset
the game how do you move on to a new system
so all this is converging right
now the the financial game is done
they're out of moves they're out of moves
interest rates are zero negative they can't
keep printing money inflation's raging high
what happens when inflation rage is high
is revolution the catalyst for almost every
single revolution is that when people can't eat
and people can't eat when the food's too
expensive um and so that's what they're facing
technology is here creating a revolution and now
politically we have a revolution it's all coming
together i think it comes to a head like i said
in the next couple years and the reason why is
because the financial system being reset all of
them being reset and then having this new system
to put us into the cbd-backed social credit
score system um and they can't wait if they
don't do something now to put us into a new system
that they can control then they lose everything
and so unfortunately i think we're going to
continue to see more crackdowns we're probably
going to see more regulations we're going
to see more censorship more de-platforming
you know more sanctions it's going to be more but
the more that they do the more people will push
back the more people they kick out of the finance
system the more people go build a parallel system
over here the more people get d platformed the
more people go create content over here like
like alex jones was the first kind of really big
name guy that got you know killed online he still
gets he still gets millions of people watching
his shows they haven't been able to stop that so
all they did was force them to go create a system
over here if you go back and you study the fall of
the ussr the fall of communism back in the 70s and
80s a couple people were very instrumental in that
so solcinicev he wrote the book uh guleg acropolos
vaclav havel he um he um he went on to become the
pres he got locked up for i think three years
for his writings but kim became the president
of yugoslavia but they did a lot of writing
it was their writing it was their information
that led to the fall of communism back then
but one thing that they talk about is that they
started to build parallel economies and so what
do i mean by that well if i get kicked out of the
financial system then i have to go use a different
form of money over here i can't fight against the
education system but i can pull my kids out and
i can put them in a homeschool pod i can't fight
against legacy media but i can go create my own
media company over here i can't fight against the
financial system but i can just pull my money out
and i can go over here and so the more they try
to restrict the more people leave the party and
by 2025 they're gonna find themselves the only
person at the party that's amazing um i also am
interested in the fact that the bitcoin halving
is around 2024 oh there's another there's
another good piece yeah so that's going to
be a really interesting part of the puzzle um you
have a book coming out the uncommunist manifesto
let's hear about it yeah so alex fetzke and i got
together a couple weeks ago and locked ourselves
in a rental in airbnb for like five days and and
and wrote a book and basically what we did is we
took the communist manifesto which i talked
about marx wrote now about 175 years ago and
the communist manifesto has basically gone it's
like an ideology that just won't die um hundreds
of millions of people have died under that uh
socialism regime and and we took that book which
most people haven't read i actually hadn't read
a tale about a year ago and it's a pamphlet it's
a booklet it's four chapters it's 8 000 words most
people can read in about 45 minutes um and i would
i would i would say that if most people would
read that book they would never look at marxism
or socialism or communism the same again most
people have this dream idea of what that is but if
they would just read that book so for example he
says communism can be summed up in one statement
abolition of private property that's one statement
wow okay so that's what it stands he says that uh
he says that the bourgeoisie the rich they
only have families they only have families
they only have kids for exploitation and they
only have wives to have kids and the bourgeoisie
the rich just share their women so he believes
that all women should just be community property
that's what he says in the book and women
are okay with that like women should just
be community property as a matter of fact
in russia they actually had that so i think
it was women from like 18 to 25 had to become
community property before they could settle down
which uh huxley wrote the book the brave new world
and that's kind of the story in that book the
brave new world um so anyway if people read that
book like if you read that book you'd probably
be pretty turned off by that right but um so what
we did is we took that book and we kept the same
structure four chapters um about 8 000 words i
think we came up with 10 000 words so it's quick
it's a less than an hour read um same structure we
took chapter by chapter and we kind of reframed it
and we called it the uncommunist manifesto and
he he wrote that the struggle which all humans
struggle in life uh find we have you know finite
resources so we all struggle but he said that
the struggle was between classes the rich and
the poor the bourgeoisie and the proletariat
hitler said that it was a struggle between
races we reframed it we said that the real
access of struggle is not between classes or
political ideologies the real access of struggle
is between the individual versus the collectivist
trying to pull them into groups and so we reframed
it from that standpoint what we're hoping is that
because it's a quick easy read because we kept the
same format we're hoping that maybe it could go
on to open people's eyes to what marxism really
is but more importantly show them a much better
system that we can organize the world around so
you can go to uncommunist.com and uh we are
launching a kickstarter campaign next week
and then we'll have printed copies at bitcoin uh
at the bitcoin conference both alex and i are both
speaking there and we'll be doing book signings
there as well oh i'm so excited to read it um i'm
so excited i think it's going to be great where
can people find out more about you follow you
i know you've obviously um you're on iheart radio
as well yeah so i have a youtube channel mark moss
and i do like um two teaching videos a week where
i dive into these types of topics um i have the
radio show on iheartradio you can just search that
mark moss radio um and then um yeah on twitter i
think we're we're streaming live to twitter so
i'm way too active on twitter i should probably
pull off a little bit one mark moss on twitter
um like i said i'm too active so if you hit me
up with questions i'll certainly answer them there
and then of course go to check out uncommunist.com
mark it's been so fascinating i want to thank
you so much for going into so much detail
i've personally learned a lot i've been reading
the comments and people have found a lot of value
in what you had to say um so thank you so much
for coming on i'm so excited to get your book
and um yeah we'll have to catch up again
sometime i'm going to be in miami as well
so um hopefully we can meet in person then
ah thanks so much it was a pleasure being
here absolutely and guys don't forget to follow
mark on twitter and definitely check out his book
and until next time i will see you
all next week thanks for tuning in